[Music]
this group of researchers couldn't be
more different
these hunters got their education living
off the land in Canada's far north the
scientists got their education at
universities in southern Canada and
Europe but in a picture increasingly
common across Canada's north these two
groups are joining forces emerging Inuit
knowledge no I'm starting to see more
disease or scopes from way back then
with science and technology the st.
marked to better understand climate
changes radical transformation of the
Arctic the relationship between science
and indigenous knowledge hasn't always
been so easy in the past
Inuit say scientists would often do
research in the Arctic and then just
leave community members say they were
seldom told about research findings or
how they might impact their lives
Inuit knowledge of the land and animals
was rarely acknowledged if it was even
used at all
Bobby Greenlee heads the hunters and
trappers organization in Cambridge Bay
Nunavut traditional knowledge is
probably one of the best things for
everybody to come up here when they do
come up here get that and then it's a
good starting point for for everybody
instead of just okay we're here if we're
gonna go out there well you can't do
that government and the scientists are
trained to listen to our requests for
them to share our you know experience
and our knowledge of you know wildlife
and the waters in the land and so it's
you know it's it will be a good benefit
for both scientists applying for grants
or research permits in parts of Canada's
north are increasingly required to show
how communities will be involved in
their work and how results will be
reported back to northerners but bobby
greenlease says barriers still remain no
matter how well-intentioned people are
he says the muskox health monitoring
program a partnership between Cambridge
Bay and the University of Calgary is an
example of what can happen when the two
groups work hand in hand thank you very
much for having us it's really it's nice
to be here and it's it's a great group
of people not too often that this happen
it's nice that he's coming forward yeah
we try to keep stuff hunters around
Cambridge Bay save it musk oxen an
animal important to their culture and
economy have been getting skinnier
sicker and further away from the
community over the last decade there's
also been an unusually high number of
musk ox deaths on Victoria and banks
islands I our family gourd on the land
and harvest our own food we've noticed
the health of our animals changing over
time and it's been a concern the
monitoring program was set up in 2010 to
better understand the impact of climate
change on these animals from the start
the scientists sought to include
everyone in the community from
subsistence hunters to the local
Outfitters our scientific presence has
not been that long but the knowledge in
the community the people who wrote on
the land are the ones who have seen more
musk oxen than I ever will see in my
lifetime they've handled more muscat and
they've got knowledge that's been passed
down over generations scientists provide
the hunters and trappers association and
the local outfitter with these kits for
the musk oxen they harvest with it
the hunters gather first samples little
blood as possible because the blood will
contaminate the hormone assay so
blood and fecal matter this is a good
case for us we can work everything up
the hunters then bring the samples back
to Mathilde Thomas le a PhD student at
the University of Calgary
okay the kits are then processed to
evaluate the animals health and identify
diseases but it's not just these kits
that are making a difference
the hunters observations and their
historical knowledge of the land and
animals are pushing scientific research
into important new areas really migrate
across but that was the first year I
actually witnessed what I learned from
the hunters very much forms my research
it allows me to move forward and to
generate some new hypotheses and to
formulate those hypotheses I can probe
with the hunters what they're seeing and
then think okay what may this mean from
a scientific perspective but capturing
that knowledge isn't always easy
Mathilde Thomas le is in charge of the
hunter interviews in Cambridge Bay
working with a translator she uses
drawings so hunters can point out the
kinds of changes they're seeing in
muskox health as for the rest it's done
with this beans researchers ask local
hunters to divide the beans and show how
their observations now compared to the
past interviews actually are a very
important tool in the program and in my
PhD study because they provide the basis
of knowledge that otherwise get missing
with the traditional way
of conducting monitoring and
surveillance only with the samples for
example the interviews and sample kit
collection is something many local
hunters have embraced when we heard of
this research happening in regards to
the moose [ __ ] but suddenly decided we
need to be part of this so we can be
able to answer some of the questions
that we have in regards to what we're
finally I know with research in science
if we can make a difference in how the
health of our animals from our food if
we can help that by taking part in this
research it's all the better not only
for today but for our animals for our
children and their grandchildren to
continue to harvest a healthy animal I'm
very thankful that I got the opportunity
to take out the biologist and learn more
from her she told us that she learned a
lot from you that yeah we learned from
each other
[Music]
researchers here say it's important to
highlight how key Inuit knowledge is to
understanding not only how climate
change is affecting the Arctic but also
how it's affecting the rest of the world
the more we can take that and use it as
a bit of a model for other systems to
understand you know how what's going to
happen with malaria what's going to
happen with a number of human diseases
or livestock diseases so this provides a
bit of a pristine model for doing some
of that work
and then is an important acknowledgment
that is not always done by researchers
ultimately what we strive to do is
develop a system where we can have
ongoing monitoring of muskox health that
incorporates these different bodies of
knowledge and integrates them it's not
this is one this is the other and there
are two different bodies but they are
together
[Music]
as for the Cambridge Bay hunters they
want to encourage other Arctic
communities to get involved in
scientific research if people can take
part in some of the research that's
happening but also request that research
happens when they see changes start
connecting start dialoguing with the
types of interviews that Matilda's been
doing I think that's where we get we get
a lot more information with those two
together - my my my work when he got
into somebody ears and liked me and I
started doing something well you know it
what we can do now might just save what
we have in the future for our children
[Music]